Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my walking dead episode
seven video Carl Grimes vs Negan.
Just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet but I actively feel like this made
up for the slow episode six last week, just
a heads up there is a new round of the walking
to give away all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video.
Make sure you click that bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss out on anything but they
should've called this episode walking dead
number 105 Carl stows away on his mission
to kill Negan.
It's a little bit longer on the TV show it's
almost the exact same plot.
So let's do top 10 WTF and comic book Easter
eggs a lot of these were copied page to screen
from the comic book like literally lifting
dialogue right off the page, so number 10
was shown makes herself a roadblock so that
she can get to Negan it slightly different
in the comics michonne goes to a different
place.
But we can address that.
We start talking about the midseason finale
to the following the comics pretty closely,
but a couple of characters are little bit
different from the comics but they are all
heading in the comic book direction like those
mattresses that the saviors burned that she's
staring at the beginning of the episode.
Carl hid under those in the comics that's
how we stowed away into the saviors compound
in the comics so I love the way they cut between
the shown and Rick like she put her walkie
down Rick wakes up in the back of the pickup
truck with Aaron in almost goes to caller
but thinks twice of it like they were all
kind of it odds here they need to come together
so that was kind of the theme of the episode.
They were slowly getting to that point where
things are so bad that they can't take it
anymore.
It is that all of the characters haven't gotten
to that place yet the place that Rosita Carl
in Michonne her in like a couple of the few
people that are actively starting to fight
back.
But number nine back to Carl and Jesus who
is super pissed when Carl does not jump off
the back of the truck with him now, his whole
mission was to make it into the saviors compound
to find where Daryl was to see if he could
break them out and do some recon so he still
doing that but Carl is in having any of that.
So number eight.
You know right out of the comics jumps out
of the back of the truck guns blazing kills
a couple of the saviors Negan is flat out
and pressed but still afraid.
So Negan is a psychopath, but he's not dumb.
So that's why he's standing behind the Savior
here before they disarmed Carl like he still
hedging his bed so when he tells Carl that
he is afraid he's actually being honest.
That's the thing about Negan is the he bowl
should it's a lot was hard to tell when he's
telling the truth and when he's busting your
balls like I like the way need to talk about
busting balls like it's no big deal in the
most psychotic way possible, so number seven
we pick up with Daryl who is now on guard
duty like you see him chained up with the
other walkers of the people who they punished.
By making them stand out there with the other
walkers that it pans out on their base right
off the page.
So like you see all the roadblocks is heavily
fortified the just trying to make it seem
like this insurmountable impregnable fortress
for the funny thing here is that while Negan's
going on and on this is kind of a runner through
the episode to is that they have like some
big exchange seem really serious, but he would
just casually slip in insoles like hey how's
the job going Daryl make fun of Carl's, I
make fun of Olivia for being fat like he just
has an autoresponder in his brain that just
throws out an insult for every regular comment
that he speaks, but number six he finally
gives the big speech and refers to them as
the saviors of the other people that we've
met have called in the saviors, but we never
heard Negan refer to them as the saviors we
has that big epic speech which was a nice
mere for Rosita speech at the end only Negan's
is kind of like the psychotic colt version
like he's this coleader he was bragging a
Carl Baha'i has them on their knees look out
cool I am like even has them on their knees
after he finishes speaking, but you do get
the sense like as he said performing for all
these people.
He did this several times in the episode were
he's kind of like Ezekiel Ezekiel did a little
bit of community theater.
So he has this flair for performance the knee
can also as it is a Negan is kind of delighting
in tormenting people in Ezekiel doesn't really
get off on it.
That way he's more of a Wizard of Oz type
character where he just keeps it up to make
everybody feel safe not to keep people under
his thumb, but number five that car ride with
Gabriel and Spencer two of the most hated
members of the save zone talking about hating
people.
The thing is is that Gabriel is kind of like
the more hopeful spin on this like he used
to be hated and he's come around and calls
Spencer out for being a Dick like look dude.
It doesn't have to be terminal then gets out
and walks back just because he can't stand
Spencer anymore but he's father Gabriel so
he's really sweet about it.
So I really love Gabriel in this moment, but
Spencer is on this really weird trip.
He's almost turning into the new Dwight like
he wants to keep the peace he wants to fight
find all the supplies and they have that funny
twist with the note read in Latin.
So he finds weapons find some food and it's
kind of like the diametric opposite of Rosita
who you know number four talks Eugene into
manning up and making her some bullets so
Rosita speech was like my other favorite big
speech in the episode besides Negan's Savior
speech.
It was this huge rally moment.
It just like the tipping point and they also
kind of teased the Rick Aaron storyline, which
will talk about in the second like Rosita
being is really bad ass female character making
a plan to take on new Negan you have much
shown who's doing the same thing and then
you have the Rick and Aaron storyline number
three which I think you know they find this
community I think it's gonna turn out to be
magna who's this female leader of another
small community near the save zone.
It just the way they use those male pronouns
when they were seeing all the signs all the
defenses that like oh this guy is heavily
armed he has this floater traps he's really
smart about his defenses I just feel like
it's a big misdirect and it's gonna be a woman
like a really bad ass female character in
magna is like the next likely candidate because
I don't think they're doing the whisperers,
this soon because the leader of the whisperers
alpha is a female two but it's way too soon
for that.
So number two Carl gets a grand tour of Negan's
compound, he needs all the wives.
This is all right out of the comics in most
WTF scene ever Negan totally gets off on seeing
Carl's I without the bandage on like even
start sketching a little makes Carl sing a
song that his mother saying to him which is
super creepy and then is he starts weeping.
You know, Carl confesses I shot my mother.
So Negan when he was saying that he was impressed
with Carl.
He was being genuine but the big twist is
that Negan is much as he was enjoying getting
to know Carl Moore was also stalling for time
till number one the iron was ready, so he
gives Mark the iron, just like he does in
the comics is another big speech.
This was a little bit creepier about the rules
about how he's trying to keep order in his
society, so that kind of ties up in with the
idea that Carl knows that Negan can't kill
him because that Would Dr., Rick over the
edge.
It would destroy the system that Negan is
trying to keep in place he does have a plan
like you not completely insane.
He really enjoys the way things are and he
knows there is a certain trick to keeping
the balance between all the different communities
that he has under his thumb are seemingly
has under his thumb.
So Carl realizing that says you can't kill
me.
So you might as well just jump out the window
to save me the trouble of killing you with
the phase iron scene I love the way they kept
flashing back to Dwight to their reactions
didn't linger on it quite as much as I expected
they cut away but maybe that's just because
the first episode with the gland in the Abraham
kill was so graphic that they wanted the dialer
back just a little bit, but this is like an
hour and half episode so I should oppression
at like five more WTF moments on this.
So really like tied for first was that final
moment with Negan cradling Judith in this
Norman Rockwell nightmare saying that he should
just killed Carl and Rick and move into the
suburbs.
So the really just trying to beat you in the
face with the idea that Meagan has to go,
so that's going to require everyone coming
together like all the communities the kingdom
Oceanside this new group of people that Rick
and Aaron are running into, and help from
the inside of the saviors to, so people like
Dwight and Sherry like Sherry seems like she's
really pissed that Dwight hasn't come around
because he still playing by Negan's rules.
So if you look at Daryl's note here I actually
think it was Sherry that let him out, just
because the handwriting looks kind of effeminate
like a less Dwight has really effeminate handwriting
you see in the next episode he's escaping.
There's so much story to get through that
I think the midseason finale is another 90
minute episode so is gonna be crazy let me
know in the comments what was your guys favorite
moment.
Do you think that they will actually decide
like Rick will meet with the other heads of
the communities including Dwight to move against
Negan in episode eight.
Do you think it's gonna be the cliffhanger
for the back half of the season and they'll
to march to war.
Like this episode was issue 105 that's in
the middle of March the war.
Volume 18 it feels like volume 19, will be
the back half of the season leading into all-out
war which is volume 20, so if you are reading
along I would recommend that you read through
volume 18 again then get ready for volume
19, before we come back for the back half
of the season here listed this way.
Leave a like if you think that Spencer is
going to be one of the next big characters
to get killed off of the show just because
he's headed in such a Dwight direction.
It seems that they're setting Dwight's character
up to crawl out of that hole to crawl out
from under Negan's thumb was can happen is
is there's like a couple really big videos
that are dropping tomorrow.
I got my Westworld finale video that will
post tomorrow morning gonna be a Transformers
trailer dropping and The Walking Dead finale
trailer so I'll try get those videos out as
fast as possible but if you have any bonus
videos for The Walking Dead the want me to
do during the midseason break just let me
know in the comments while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here to rewatch
the guardians of the Galaxy trailer and you
can click here for all my Westworld videos
thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!